[Musique]
allez on va passer au top 1 et ses
manuels gitans qui répond qu on cherche
on va voir on va voir l'extrait parce
que je vous le dis c'est un truc de fou
il a même appelé mon père non mais je
voulais c'est quoi il ya un numéro je
voulais vous les révéler il a trouvé le
numéro de mon père il a même appelé mon
père manuel gitans et pas pour le vu
passer quand même
non non non il a été plutôt cool et suit
mon père y voilà il y arriver voilà on y
voit là mais bon voilà donc au début ce
qu'un petit peu chaud et après les
calmer et ils sont devenus très potes
d'ailleurs je crois qu'ils s'appellent
tous les jours mais je vous jure qu'il a
appelé mon père il ya quelques semaines
donc on nous avions fait la rencontre du
d'emmanuel d'immanuel gitans et veut
qu'on l'appelle comme ça dans un
reportage de 90 minutes enquête
consacrée aux cambriolages et dans
l'extrait que nous avions diffusé sur le
plateau de thé pmp manu gitans nous
expliquer comment cambrioler une maison
et vous allez voir ce qu'avaient dit les
chroniqueurs et juste après manu le
gitan faudra s'expliquer c'est pas un
ex-braqueur pour qui le fric frac n'a
aucun secret 18,85 ça va c'est très bien
comme ats pour le prix est très bien
gamme en tôle où il accrocha comme ça
ici il a un grand pantalon et l'homme et
life et celui qui boite avec une
béquille il encore moins suspect pour
être devant la maison groix parce que
suivant quand voyages.fr si vous rentrez
qu'une voiture il ya un gars qui passe à
pied il peut être le cadenas le gaz se
gardent moins que la voiture il descend
il ouvre le portail alors manouches
gitans est avec nicolas peut dire merci
manu
[Applaudissements]
je sais aussi merci manu d'être là alors
manu jous on va montrer ce que vous avez
dit parce qu'on s'en souvient pas merci
manu en tout cas des plats est à l on va
on va raconter non mais c'est courageux
de tabarre déjà à temps résume appelé au
téléphone comme moyen terme c'est à dire
non mais d'accord la première à dumas
pose à l'abri comme quoi mais non non
non non tu devais venir une fois on a dû
tout annuler parce qu'on avait trop de
choses
noms adresses pas les deux sessions
annulés et des meufs aussi j'en ai
donnés je peux te dire mais c'est pas
grave les meufs tu peux c'est pas grave
mais toi non pinana savent pas où tu
habites mais moi je souhaitais mais bien
parce que je sais pas ce rappel on a
fait une belle émission ensemble un jour
keith island eric lopez sur les peurs ah
ouais ouais c'est possible relégué au
drugstore champs elysées ah oui là non
c'est un truc assez longue durée mais
j'avais fracassé un pédophile il annoncé
sa direct on est en train de manger pas
alors alors à l'allégeance en train de
manger aussi développé et est revenue
sur le truc voilà merci alors manu
regarde regarde ce qu'avaient dit les
chroniqueurs regarde très basses que à
la havane où il est énervé il a même
appelé mon père mais ils étaient 120 g
ahmed on perd parce qu'il est médecin
ben on le sait et c'était le seul qui
pouvait faire un diagnostic vital pour
toi
les automatiques mans je me suis dit il
ya des gens qui vont profiter notre
conflit tous les deux ouais parce que
c'est sûr il ya beaucoup de gens qui
t'aiment pas ouais moi je te regarde et
ça me faisait rigoler et tout ce que
j'aime pas chez toi y'a pas de problème
on va en discuter doigts voilà et en
fait je me suis dit si j'appelais son
père c'est obligé que la communication
soit passé ouais moi quand vraiment même
interpol me cherche
j'appelle mon père ta mère est world un
père l'aurait bon on dit ok je suis prêt
pour la garde à vue je mets les
mocassins sans lacets d'accord
l'habitude et mon père qui va d'accord
ou ton père t'a passer le message
ouais ouais ouais nan patronat dit non
et il est normal
non non il n'y a pas de coup de pression
alors âgé pas été jusque encore se
chercher ils sont les connais tous les
jours le garde-corps salaires jugés
souvent là-bas on regarde ces partis
n'accusez pas révélation il faut un
pied-de-biche à une pince pour combler
ça n'a aucune valeur d'information c'est
juste pour faire de l'audience
moi ça me choque profondément faire
c'est totalement inutile c'est honteux
vous devriez être choqué je ne pouvais
pas encourager alors alors déjà c'est ça
c'est monsieur mekhissi vous énervez pas
snob vous explique oui parce que je vais
je pas fait l'histoire du tout ouais
c'est ça c'est l'histoire du tuto dont
je vais vous la sortie des images d'un
contexte mais oui mais on a sorti des
images d'un contexte parce qu'après vous
avez appelé toutes les rédactions
puisque je sais pas le parisien était au
courant et my les annuaires do we may en
émotions sur les amis par les malades ou
les deux oui non mais je te lis faut se
calmer mais amalgamer ou non il ne
mangeait de dire oui ça va pas besoin de
faire un coup pression longtemps mal à
faire le show du fc beausoleil peut
faire le show avec mangeait pas souhaité
toi moi si on me le dit je suis hyper
content qu est ce qu un moment j'en ai
une chez toi je tape à la porte je suis
dit voilà j'adore mais c'est bon tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure et en plus ils
vous reprendre le truc quand je le jeudi
tu m'a invité pour une hache et toi je
ne voulais pas venir c'est maxime que
j'ai eus je dis juste que cyril fasse un
démenti est assorti d à l'orage dans
l'air est alors quasiment qu'est ce qui
me dérange mais pour kim ce qui me
dérange c'est que j'ai expliqué comment
en fait sécuriser une maison
ouais ça veut dire comme parent ici si
on veut rentrer chez elles ou là on
rentre même pas elle est ici un mail
rapporte ya pas de barreaux ouais il ya
pas de boy à rien donc si je veux
revenir un jour je rentre par la fenêtre
je me pose enfin supermarché déchets je
reviens par la halle aux chaussures et
mais ce que je veux dire j'ai expliqué
quelque chose de concret donc tu penses
tout à fait non mais qu'a fait un truc
pédagogique pour les gens pour ce pur à
se protéger savait nager je m'adresser
aux gens torah et maison
ouais on a monté les barreaux aux
fenêtres on a monté à aucun moment
gilles moi c'est comment on pouvait
servir d'un pied de biche
j'ai montré que luna encore on avait bu
ou encore eux n'ont pas encore osé quand
même très comment servir d'un
pied-de-biche vous l'avez peut-être
envisager comment ça s'est passé
d'accord à mon but je suis non mais on
peut soit l'apologie de quelque chose
voilà c'est ça veut dire que si on
regarde comprend quatre minutes tout se
passe à l'antenne je fais l'apologie de
rien du tout voilà juste vous pensez
juste manu vous aider les gens à mieux
se protéger contre les cambriolages et
je suis souvent et si vous avez fait une
enquête
même au crédit agricole gd remercions
agricole j'ai fait des audits de
sécurité sur les banques parce que je
suis rentré dans n'importe quelle banque
pour les attendre à un intérieur quoi
vous êtes déjà rentré dans des banques
comme ses adversaires c'est mon métier
c'était mon métier
bah oui ah ouais ouais skin appelé jean
aussi fort mais je veux dire la corab en
lumière sa mémoire est-ce que vous
pouvez kidnappé mathieu mathieu mathieu
non mais tu es route rami l'annuler tout
le monde est sympa ici man on man u tout
le monde et ça moi mais je te le dis je
tenais tout le monde est sympa je sais
je sais que ça va mais si tu veux on a
dénaturé quelque chose ça va c'est bon
et norah jones prend exemple sur toi y'a
pas de problème
moi j'ai vu un truc sur tout a super
bien pour la prévention routière
oui voilà qui était bien fait je trouve
ça bien c'est tout a lieu à chaque fois
c'est super la table un projet si cher
les images du contexte et je prends de
deux phrases ou thani à balmoral et tout
hambourg et bah ouais mais c'est ça en
fait mal on va pas on va falloir un
débat là-dessus les séries je voudrais
juste moi manu m'a demandé d'avoir un
droit de réponse est bien sûr sa bande à
manu c'est important que tu viennes
voilà parce que tu as on a tous les
médias en ont parlé
voilà tous les journalistes tous a donc
manu est venu il voulait dire qu'il
faisait de la prévention voilà et que
mais nous ici manu je t'explique quelque
chose on est dans une émission où on
rigole
si vertueux je t'explique on prend un
extrait on va pas faire un truc dessus
oui mais non il a par exemple tout bon
voir les maîtres g et la non mais là
c'est pas un sujet grave et je suis
désolé tu faisais un tuto de pour
commencer comment se protéger contre les
cambriolages
c'était assez marrant comment s'étaient
présentés dans le reportage maintenant
t'es pas producteur de l'émission donc
je te dise est apte à voile à tapas t'as
pas tort at on vouloir nous n'avez rien
contre toi on a dit voilà regarder
comment était présenté le truc là on en
a rigolé on rigole de tout ici à ford si
tu veux venir rigole avec nous tu es le
bienvenu quand tu veux brown mais on n'a
pas de problème avec toi et on vous
verra-t-on bientôt
moi ce que j'ai dit est un peu l'idole
des jeunes d'accord mais c'est bon manu
parce qu'on a on a fini la lazio rome
voilà merci de me dire merci d'être
venus merci et merci manu d'avoir les
conducteurs dont je n'y arrive pas et on
n'a rien contre toi et moi je voulais
pas que les militaires c'est mon chéri
plein d'amour merci merci manu et merci
les maires du lot d'histoires bon ben
voilà mes chéris on donnera toujours des
droits de réponse dans touche pas moi là
et manu qui est un mec en plus très
sympas ils vont perdre adore manu mon
père tu adores en plus il m'a saoulé
avec toi donc voilà comme ça c'est fait